so when we put together innovation
there's a lot of chaos and there's a lot
we don't know and we're looking for
guidance in the process that will help
us navigate through the innovation
process what business models do is they
don't create a checklist but they give
us a process in that process shows us
what are the things that we need to do
enables us to actually navigate in a
structured way through the innovation
process when we talk about commercial
innovations because there is so much
that is unstructured when we create an
innovative business the discipline that
comes from business model analysis
enables us and guides us on the
structured part so we don't need to
spend too much time and attention on it
if we do it right and we can really
focus on the unstructured creative parts
which is where a lot of the innovation
comes from
what we do in the course is start by
identifying what are the key elements of
a business model and I try to do it at a
high level in three parts because
anything here is more than three parts
it's too complex we don't understand
that so step one let's see what are the
top three parts of a business model that
are the value creation model the profit
model and the logic of the business that
explains why it's going to work what we
then do is perform a detailed analysis
of the company called Dropbox that
enables people to share to store and
share data with themselves really
between their different computers and
with other people and we analyze in
detail what is the structure of the
business model for that company in the
next a a module that we go into is a
module that looks into an important
family of business models especially in
the technology fields which are business
models they're based on network effects
and we try to understand what are some
of the difficulties in what are some of
the advantages of building and network
effects based business model so in the
last module what we're going to do is
take the different elements we've
learned and put together a business
model and present it in a structured way
so that all of us can practice what
we've learned and hopefully actually
build new business models
to think in concrete terms about success
in failure success is essentially the
result of your large number of failures
so the way we need to think about
success and failure is a how do we fail
in a structured way so that we can tend
turn the failures into a success so
think about each failure is another
stepping stone towards success as
opposed to a failure don't be
disappointed that's the question what
can I learn from it what does it mean
and what is the next step I need to take
in order to be more successful